-Welcome back, everybody.
We're hanging out with Simu Liu
right there.
-Still tired. Still tired.
-A little bit still, yeah.
Congrats, again, on the success
of "Shang-Chi."
This is a massive, massive,
massive, massive movie.
-Thank you.
-There must be a sequel talk
in the works or maybe not.
Or we don't know?
Does Marvel let you know?
-Look, I feel like there may
have a been a day and age
where they brought the actors in
and they were like,
"Hey, buddy, here's everything
that's going to happen."
But I just feel like there were
certain things that happened
that ruined it for all of us,
so...
I don't want to single anybody
out, but, you know,
shout-out to Holland,
shout-out to Ruffalo.
[ Laughter ]
They really just mucked it up
for the rest of us.
So, no, no, we have no idea.
-You're also doing
a really cool thing
on Thanksgiving Day
with "Sesame Street."
Can you let everyone know
what you're doing?
-Yeah, well, we are doing
kind of a special episode
kind of centered on AAPI issues.
And we're actually introducing
the very first
Asian American muppet.
Her name is Ji-Young.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
-There's you.
That's cool. Come on.
-It's just so incredible.
I mean, it's not every day,
first of all,
that you get to see faces, you
know, certain faces on screen.
And now we have it
in muppet form.
And kids everywhere will get to
kind of enjoy and hang out with
Ji-Young and learn her name and
her culture and all that stuff.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Dude, I'm so --
I'm so excited.
And again, I want you to break
a leg on "Saturday Night Live."
Are you nervous at all?
-I am a little bit.
-You have to be
a little nervous.
But you're a performer.
-I'm such a big fan
of your work.
And I know that your impressions
are just world class.
And so, in my -- like, I had
a Zoom call on Monday
where they were like, "Hey, give
us any ideas that you have."
And I was kind of like, "Well, I
have prepared some impressions."
[ Laughter ]
And -- And none of them made it.
-Okay. Okay.
But are these impressions of --
-Well, yeah, like, you do, like,
these really cool, like,
pop culture celebrity
impressions.
And I, you know, mine are not
exactly that.
-Can you give me an example of
an impression?
-Yeah. So I do, like,
an Emperor Palpatine.
[ Laughter ]
Like, that's what I --
[ Cheers ]
-You do Emperor Pal--
-I do Emperor Palpatine.
So, you know,
it's something like...
-I'm going to close my eyes.
-[ Deep voice ] "Something,
something, something dark side."
[ Cheers and applause ]
"I am very excited to be hosting
'Saturday Night Live.'"
-Wow. And, so, they didn't bite
on that one?
-[ Normal voice ]
They did not bite on it.
Honestly, I didn't want to say,
I'm a little offended.
[ Laughter ]
-What other ones did you throw
by them?
-So then I was like, well, for
sure they would go for Gollum.
They would go for Gollum,
'cause I practiced Gollum.
You know, I like to think that
I'm a pretty good one.
So it goes a little something
like this.
[ Clears throat ]
[ as Gollum ] Those tricksy
little Hobbitses.
Master tricks us.
Master deceives us.
Master loves Jimmy Fallon."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I like that! I like that!
-[ Normal voice ]
Well, thank you.
-I like that!
-Thank you.
-Simu Liu, I love you, buddy.
Break a leg this Saturday.
-Thank you so much.
-"Shang-Chi and the Legend
of the Ten Rings"
is streaming now on Disney+.
Check him out on "Saturday Night
Live" this Saturday.
You'll see none of
these impressions.